hi guys it's silver at again and I got a
request to do a tutorial on the flying
camera roots editor and I figured that I
would just do it since I found some
tutorials on it but they didn't quite
cover everything so I just figured I'm
gonna cover all of the random stuff that
you won't even use probably but just try
and cover everything about it but first
I'm just gonna yeah explain the basics
of this and basically what you need to
make some nice little clips with this so
let's get started first of all I always
like to change my camera mode to either
advanced or free look just depends on
what you want advanced is really handy
if you want to focus on an inversion for
example you can kind of zoom in on it
and then kind of move around it like
this but then again some people really
like to use the free look camera as it
does offer a bit more freedom as you can
just basically rotate around and zoom in
on things to basically get a very nice
view of things now I am very much used
to the advanced camera so I'm just gonna
use that right now so there are two ways
of actually getting the flying camera
routes editor and one way is to press
ctrl shift + f11 at the same time but
since my keyboard is totally [ __ ] up I
can't do that
so I'm gonna use a cheat rename a guest
Deline like this and press Enter to get
this and now this is the flying camera
routes editor and to get all of the many
interesting possibilities up all you
need to do is click a new row which is
supposed to say new routes but it
doesn't and there you got all this and
now this might be very confusing but
I'll just give you the basics well first
of all you can see that it's right now
pointing over there and that makes no
sense but there are two ways of adding
points for the camera to go so because
the way this works is you basically add
points for the camera to go and where it
should look and if you add another point
it's going to connect the two points
with a line where they come where the
camera is going to fly over and there
are two ways to add these one of them
is to suppress inserts and you'll see
that the camera over here in the preview
screen by the way if this is not working
that's because of this little option if
you turn this off like this you won't
see it but if you turn it on you'll see
the preview on I definitely recommend
turning that on because it's very
helpful and you can see that I now see
this and if I press insert one more time
you can see two squares over here and
now each both the one both of these
squares represent one piece on the
timeline of the camera root thing and if
I press insert one more time you're
going to see another little block and
this by the way this big gray thing is
the preview well I don't know what to
call it
but you can move around this by with
well with your mouse basically and you
can see what kind of path the camera
takes so as you can see the first ones
are pretty much the same but actually no
the second ones are pretty much the same
and this is because if you click insert
it's gonna insert another block at the
beginning so for example if I go over
here and insert another one it's gonna
go over here so as you can see this is
now the camera route and that's not very
great so I usually recommend using these
the s and the F okay I'm just gonna
click on new routes because this route
is trash if you want to start all over
again because your route is just
terrible and you know it's bad basically
you can just click new route and it's
empty again so what I usually do is I
start with one point for example over
here and this is where I want to start
my route and I press s this is this is
gonna add a block at the start now if I
want to add a block at the end so if I
want to move move the camera from over
there to here then I want to press F
that means it adds another block at the
end and not at the beginning like the
insert button usually like the insert
button does so I usually use as an F for
this and now as you can see on this
little preview thing it's now moving
from my first point to my second point
and this is exactly what we want
also you can press this play button just
to see yeah and just to see whether you
like it or not
now as you can see it does move quite
slowly now this is the last thing to the
basics of it that I want to address and
that is this little red bar now this is
gonna be very important this blue bar
does I don't even exactly sure what this
blue bar does really but you don't I
don't think you really need it there's a
wait what does that do no let's see this
one appeared to do anything doesn't
really move anything anyway the red bar
is the speed of the clip so if for
example I turn this up well pretty much
all the way up then it moves very fast
and if I turn it all the way down it's
gonna be extremely slow now this is just
gonna the best thing you can do with
this honestly is just slide it around
and see what kind of speed you like best
I usually put it somewhere over here and
get a nice little gentle speed but not
too slow now if you think okay I like
this I'm fine with this little flying
camera thing then all you need to do is
press record and it's gonna record a
clip for you and have to wait a little
while and as you can see it's really
likely right now and this is not a
problem this is just the in-game
recording doing its work recording and
shooting frame for frames so that takes
a very long time but it will result in a
very smooth video file on the end and
now I'm just gonna wait for this to play
as you can see it's it's pretty much
real-time the Ducks aren't going fast or
anything and I think it's almost over
right now and this is a tricky part
because it doesn't automatically stop
recording so if for example right now it
is still actually recording you can tell
by the fact that that duck is moving
very slowly and they're still likey so
if you want to stop the recording you
need to press as well whatever a
shortcut you have for recording for me
that's f11 okay so if you like this and
you can see that right now you're
actually stuck in this frame so if you
want to move again what I usually do is
I just click on a new route and then
you're all fine again so that's the way
that works and that's pretty much the
basics of it so that's all you need to
create some decent flying camera route
things but there are loads of buttons on
here that
still serve some functions and I'm just
gonna slowly go over some of the things
of this okay so first of all I'm just
gonna create a new little route I'm just
gonna zoom in on the lift Hill over
there and see what I can do with that
okay now first of all there's this very
handy thing which is called new target
smoothing now for example if I play and
this thing on the preview right here
that's all by the way first of all I
want to show this you can do this and
then if you play it it's gonna play the
clip on the full screen so that's very
handy if you want to see what it looks
like you can also use the solo play mode
but that's it gets rid of the interface
thing of the flying camera so I don't
usually do that but anyway if you want
if you want to it to be a little bit
more smooth for example it's kind of
doing some weird stuff then you can
well basically turn this on and as you
can see it's somewhat more smooth at the
beginning as you can see if I turn it
off it's gonna go straight for little
like one second and then it's gonna do
the turn but if you turn it on it's
gonna be one big turn so you can see
that the camera movement is more smooth
and linear and doesn't do weird jiggle
things anyway that's pretty handy in
some cases now I'm just gonna turn both
of those things off right now and also
some other things like recalculate this
is gonna just recalculate the movement
of the camera sometimes make a bit
better and smoother then there is the
control thing which you can use actually
to for example you can see here in the
line of my flying camera where you can
see the dots as well actually though
they're represented by little camera
things of where the camera is going and
the direction it's pointing towards as
you can see this big camera on the line
is actually something that you can grab
and just move the line around and use
different things with that depending on
whether you clicked on control knots as
you can see I'm now doing other
movements than I just did and the same
works for this this is and the direction
that it's gonna hide towards as you can
see if I move it you can see in the
preview that the camera is going to do
some weird
stuff and basically you can use this to
point the camera towards a specific
place but I usually don't use this since
it's not all that user-friendly and
usually just clicking S&F will do in
most cases now let's say for example
that I think this last thing is actually
not on the location then I want it to be
and I want to replace it with something
else you need to click on it go wherever
you want to go next and say sets
position now it's going to set the
position of that dots to where I'm
standing right now so as you can see it
changed the entire flying camera routes
thing to make a route that actually goes
over here and if I for example go over
here and set position again it's going
to change the route again so this is
very handy if you mess up on your route
and just think that you want to slightly
change it and slightly change the
location of one of their dots and you
can just use that and same works for
time if you just think that let me add
another dot in here if you think that
you want to add this one over here you
can set time and it'll move over there
and as you can see this also means that
the first point will be slightly faster
than the second part as there is kind of
the same distance covered in but in a
shorter amount of time as you can see
the time it's represented by the space
between the dots and that's pretty much
its and if you don't think no I want to
delete this all you need to do is just
delete this delete button deletes the
dots and this delete button you should
watch out for that one it's just going
to delete the entire flying camera thing
and that's pretty much it there's one
last thing that you might be confused
but but that's not really anything too
special this is the way that's the
camera while moving movement thing works
you can see camera world and local and
this all is something just for this
little thing if you change it to world
it's gonna actually snap on the grid
overall echo second three and if you
change it to local it's gonna snap to
the location of the line so as you can
see it's going to be parallel to that
line so that's pretty much that
and then I think I've pretty much
covered everything yeah that's it the
last thing is if you're if you're done
with your route you can just save it
give it a name over here and let's just
call this one cool routes and you can
save it and and just add another name
over here you can see that I've saved
another one already and if you want to
load a routes for example and this this
works in cases where you need to record
a park but what I'm recording you need
to go like something happens like mom
calls you for dinner now you can just
save it and open it another time and
load it by using the loads thing and as
you can see there's narwhals I could
just open that thing this is a camera
route thing that I made earlier and as
you can see you can just take that and
get the same route and just try it so
that's really handy in some cases now
that's everything about the flying
camera routes editor I hope you learned
something our or enjoyed the video and
thanks for watching
why